فكره تناولتها روايات وافلام الخيال
العلمي عبر سنوات هل سيكون بامكاننا
التحدث مع الموتى بشكل مباشر في يوم من
الايام اليوم يبدو اننا وصلنا المستقبل
بالفعل وهناك العديد من الشركات التي تعمل
على تطبيق الفكره وازاحه التواصل مع
الاحباء الراحلين عبر الهاتف او الفيديو
او لمساعده الصوتي في 2020 صمامه فريق
انتاج وترقيات في كوريا صوره ثلاثيه
الابعاد لطفله توفيت بسبب مرض عضال عندما
لجات والدتها الى الواقع الافتراضي بحثا
عن المواساه وحقق الفيديو مشاهده
بالملايين في جميع انحاء العالم
المساعد الصوتي اليكسا قد يتمكن قريبا من
التحدث اليك باصوات معينه مثل الاصوات
الاقارب المتوفين او حتى المشاهير
الراحلين وهو ما جاء في اعلان نشالته
امازون في يونيو الماضي
خلال العام الماضي وفي الذكرى الخامسه
والثلاثين لوفاتها اجرى برنامج فرنسي
حوارا تلفزيونيا مع الفنانه العالميه
الراحله داليدا بمساعده الذكاء الاصطناعي
تتحدث فيه عن حياتها وبدايتها